2021 marks the anniversary of some of
our favorite titles
new and old so i'm hopping in the time
machine and going on a tour of some of
the biggest anniversaries
we'll be seeing this year largely based
on u.s release dates
let us know which ones you were
surprised to see on the list and
remember to like and subscribe
for deeper dives into these classic
games throughout the year
contrary to the name marvel vs capcom 3
is actually the fifth main installment
of capcom's crossover series marvel vs
capcom
and released a whopping 11 years after
its predecessor
marvelous capcom 2. marvel 3 was the
first game in the series to move away
from 2d sprites and instead used 3d
character models
less than a year later an updated
version of the game known as ultimate
marvel vs capcom 3
was released with new characters new
stages and various character tweaks
imbalances
marvel 3's popularity boomed in the
competitive scene which hosts some of
the largest fighting game tournaments in
the world
dark souls was the spiritual successor
to from software's demon souls and
the game took the budding soul style
gameplay from niche interest to
establishing it as its own sub-genre of
games
it's intricate and unforgiving combat
sparked a new generation of games that
just
want you to die and i mean that in the
best way possible
despite the difficulty it is still
considered to be one of the best games
of all time and cemented from software
as
masters of their craft released on
october 18th
2011 two years after the incredible
arkham asylum
arkham city threw us back into the world
of the dark knight and sent us on a wild
ride
around a section of gotham city in chaos
the ongoing rivalry of batman and joker
the large-scale world a new adversary in
the form of hugo strange
and the flawless voice acting of mark
hamill and kevin conroy
lets this game live absolutely rent free
in my head
even 10 years later arkham city went on
to have multiple dlc missions
skin packs maps and more before the
series continued to expand the
arkhamverse with another mainline
installment spin-offs and of course the
upcoming suicide squad killed the
justice league
in 2022 on november 11th 2011
we visited skyrim's beautifully massive
world
filled to the brim with compelling
stories varied
tasks epic dragon battles and so much
more
not only did skyrim change the way we
look at open world games
it has created lasting memes an
incredibly active mod scene and has
many still playing to this day on every
platform under the sun
three dlcs were released for skyrim but
in 2013 bethesda announced that they'd
be
moving on from the title and would only
be releasing minor updates to skyrim as
needed fast forward to present day and
elder scrolls 6 is confirmed but
no set release date has been given just
yet
despite the title kingdom hearts 2 is
actually the third installment of the
kingdom hearts series
and picks up a year after the events of
chain of memories which
came out on the game boy advance once
again the game mashes up favorites from
both disney and final fantasy
as you follow sora donald and goofy in
search of their friends kairi and riku
while in an ongoing battle against the
mysterious organization 13.
the kingdom heart series has gone on to
see a number of additional games
released
including sequels a vr game a music
rhythm title
mobile games and mini bundles collecting
the saga
[Music]
on august 8 2006 we met frank west
the part-time macgyver and full-time
photojournalist
battling massive crowds of zombies and
uncovering the truth
dead rising's zombie survival action an
ability to use or combine
a wide variety of objects into deadly
weapons
made it an incredibly popular xbox 360
title
and the series went on to have three
sequels the original eventually made its
way to just about
everywhere with versions on the wii on
mobile
and then a re-release on xbox one and
ps4 five years ago to celebrate its
10th anniversary we even saw frank west
make an appearance in one of our earlier
entries
ultimate marvel vs capcom 3 as a
playable character
although i'd honestly prefer a zombie
horde over level 3x factor virgil
any day our favorite
head-smashing chainsawing locust
fighting series
began 15 years ago on november 7th 2006.
gears of war offered a single-player or
co-op campaign that introduced
your fight for humanity against the
locust horde
and also had a captivating multiplayer
that became the second most played game
on xbox live in 2007 with
good ol halo 2 being at number one the
game's
stunning visuals and satisfyingly gory
gunplay
made it stand out from the pack and show
the next generation of console shooters
gears of war had four major updates that
added a variety of maps and game modes
and the success of the title led to
multiple sequels and prequels
and an entire studio set up to handle
the future of the franchise
[Music]
devil may cry introduced us to dante the
pizza eating demon hunter with a serious
sibling rivalry on october 16 2001.
double may cry actually started out as
an early version of resident evil 4
but was later made into its own
independent title as its style strayed
too far from the resident evil vision
and it turned out to be the perfect
choice the game's cool and demonic
aesthetic
mixed with its combo heavy and stylish
combat proved to be a winning formula
and a nice iteration on the survival
horror genre capcom had been so
successful with devil may cry went on to
have four more mainline installments and
directly inspired other iconic titles
such as bayonetta and god of war now all
we need
is that dante bayonetta crossover
halo combat evolved need i say more
november 15 2001 was a historic event
it marked the beginning of the halo
series turn master chief into a
household name
and set the bar for console first-person
shooters halo was an xbox launch title
and the series went on to spawn
many sequels with halo 5 being the most
recent mainline installment
the next chapter halo infinite is
currently in development and set to be
released this year
halo has not only become one of the
highest grossing video game franchises
of all time
but also one of the highest in media as
well with animated short films
books and more based on the halo
universe including
an upcoming tv show on showtime not to
mention the birth of community made
classics like rooster teeth red versus
blue
a lot has been accomplished in 20 years
and i'm ready to join chief for 20
more
[Music]
super smash bros was definitely a hit
but melee
was a home run all playable characters
from the first game
made their return and many new faces
from numerous nintendo franchises
joined the popular crossover game the
success of melee spanned from casual to
competitive
with high level tournaments and
exhibitions the series has gone on to
see the release of
three more mainline installments with
super smash bros ultimate being the most
recent which is
still regularly updated with new
characters
pokemon is too monumental to leave out
so we're making an exception and going
by japan's release date for pokemon red
in blue
february 27 1996 marked the beginning of
the powerhouse franchise that would go
on to expand across all types of media
and also become one of the highest
grossing video game franchises
of all time the pokemon company would
also go on to create
many different types of games across a
wide variety of platforms and handhelds
making it accessible to nearly everyone
whether you like rpgs
snapping pics of pokemon mini games or
even puzzles
there's probably something for you and
you can't forget about
mobile how about a bonus anniversary
pokemon go is turning five this year
and to this day pokemon is still going
strong and has already teased a 25th
anniversary celebration for 2021.
the resident evil series launched march
30th 1996
and paved the way for not only the
survival horror genre
but renewed interest in zombies and pop
culture we were introduced to chris
redfield
jill valentine and stars in their
ongoing battle against the nefarious
umbrella corporation
capcom went on to create a powerhouse
collection of games in the series
and with resident evil village planned
for release this year it will add
another game
to the massive catalog for the series
that's if
you include remakes resident evil's
legacy expands beyond games as it's also
an incredibly successful movie franchise
for better or for worse
first person arena shooter quake was
released on
july 22 1996 and was the successor to id
software's doom series
quake was made in a brand new game
engine offering full
real-time 3d rendering and more quake
was also able to capitalize on the
popularity of multiplayer death matches
that was sparked by doom and finding
online multiplayer matches was
easier than ever the first quakecon was
organized a month later with an annual
event
every year since that would give the
competitive fan base a place to meet up
compete see the doves and more
25 years ago we were introduced to the
box smashing bandicoot with the killer
dance news
crash bandicoot's first game released on
september 9 1996
and the series itself has had quite the
lifespan since
a variety of titles were released from
97 to 2010
including a few fun kart racers and
direct sequels
but there was a 7 year hiatus before the
2017 release of the insane trilogy
which remastered the original three
crash bandicoot games
a couple years later we got a new
remaster for crash team racing
and the next main installment of the
series crash bandicoot 4
it's about time cultural icon lara croft
made her debut with the release of tomb
raider on november 14th
1996. as the title suggests you made
tombs
fight animals who were constantly trying
to eat you
and solve dangerous puzzles in ancient
ruins
all while duel building pistols and just
generally being a total badass
tomb raider's success inevitably led to
many more games
movies and cross promotion with lara
herself as she became one of the most
recognizable video game protagonists of
all time
earned multiple guinness world records
and pioneered strong female characters
in games
the series went on to receive 12 main
line installments
not including mobile games and other
spin-offs
the further back we go the more
prominent the arcade titles are going to
be
and for many arcades are synonymous with
street fighter
street fighter 2 was released for arcade
systems in march of 1991
and was the second installment in the
street fighters series
sf2 introduced the concept of
command-based special moves like the
iconic shuriyukin
a six-button configuration a combo
system
and a wider selection of unique
characters capcom would go on to release
numerous street fighter titles in the
mainline series as well as various
spin-offs
and game-changing crossover titles such
as marvel vs capcom and street fighter
cross tekken
to this day street fighter tournaments
exhibitions and more are held by capcom
and the fighting game community it's
been 30 years since we first saw sonic
zipping and zooming around collecting
rings and crushing robotnik
sonic was literally designed as a mascot
for sega and was a huge success as
the release of the first game helped put
the genesis on the map as a must-have
console at a time when it was competing
with the likes of the snes
sonic has been hard at work since 1991
with over 75
sonic titles in various forms being
released
not including any appearances or
crossovers like super smash bros
[Music]
our second release date exception is for
zelda
the legend of zelda was released in
japan in february of 1986
but made its way to north america in
july of 87
on the nes this legendary action
adventure game
introduced us to link and his quest to
save hyrule and princess zelda
with its mix of puzzles battle and
exploration
the legend of zelda series honed these
core pillars and expanded to dozens of
titles
with even more iconic adventures such as
lynx awakening
ocarina of time and majora's mask to
name a few
and the legacy isn't stopping there as
fans patiently wait for the release of
the breath of the wild sequel
in august of 1986 we met bounty hunter
samus iran and joined her as she
protected the galaxy from pirates
and parasites this action-adventure
series really boomed in popularity with
super metroid about 8 years later
but metroid is still known for its dark
atmosphere immersive music and mixture
of shooting and platforming gameplay
with about a dozen titles under its belt
the metroid series has seen
various styles of gameplay and the
newest installment of the series metro
prime 4
is still in the works the new
installments may be a little more story
driven than previous titles based on job
listings that popped up online in
october of 2020
looking for someone to help write
impactful stories 35 years later
in samus's adventures aren't done yet
donkey kong made his debut on july 31
1981
and was made to help nintendo break into
the north american market
the game not only introduced dk but also
introduced jumpman which is now as we
know him
mario dk and mario would go on to be two
of the most popular nintendo characters
and the game itself would become one of
the most popular arcade games of all
time
nintendo went on to release about 30
additional dk titles including the
popular
donkey kong country series and other
favorites like donkey kong 64
and the dk racing titles
40 years ago we learned just how hard it
was for an
innocent little frog to find his way
home frogger was released on october 23
1981 in arcades and had a
straightforward objective
hop across traffic and a river with way
too many logs
to get all the frogs home safe the
success of frogger led to the release of
over 30 frogger titles that spanned
arcades
consoles handheld mobile and even casino
games
the simple yet addictive format has held
strong throughout the years
and even made its way to pop culture in
the form of cartoons and even
an episode of seinfeld quite a few games
barely missed our five year increment
criteria such as the original gta
although happy 20th to gta 3
and other games like mario but all of
them are just as important
as we grow older alongside our favorite
games it's nice to take a look back at
where they started
and to see how far they've come since
then much like us
so which game made you feel old and
dusty
let us know in the comments before you
go searching for the fountain of youth
however if you want to continue your
stroll down memory lane
you should check out our video on all of
gamespot's choices for game of the year
starting from 1996. can you guess which
one was our first
thanks for watching and don't forget to
like subscribe and check out our channel
first
for all of the latest in gaming see ya
[Music]
[Applause]
you